what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today
so today we are gonna
john john
you're so annoying sorry
[Music]
adi ho reject nation so we're gonna
watch the trailer for the conjuring the
devil made me do it
the devil is getting canceled today it's
about time it's long overdue
i want to thank uh warner media for
sending us over
this this special little box yesterday
you know it had uh some fun stuff you
know what you should go to my instagram
and twitter a completely shameful plug
to watch that video
now we gotta like the trailer we have to
now we have to
they know they're watching only so much
chilling in my
life yeah if they don't keep those
checks coming it's gonna be hard to keep
doing this out of the kindness of our
own heart
speaking of which keep a lookout for our
mortal kombat review later on today when
the embargo lifts let's get into it
you okay there jesus
oh there's no jesus with you
[Applause]
[Music]
shocked this today by the broad daylight
murder of bruno sauls
the court accepts the existence of god
every time a witness swears to tell the
truth
[Music]
that is true they accept the existence
of the devil
that's a cool tease
and a cool argument
[Music]
i know
waterbed scare let's do it
cool awesome very cool shot
something terrible happened here
great visuals man all right
indiana conjuring at the end that looks
so
fun it does yeah that looks fun
it does it looks like a looks like a lot
i really enjoy these movies
i forgot how much i do but when i watch
them there's only a couple of them i
don't really like out of this whole
conjuring universe i mean the conjuring
ones are the best
yeah i've had a conjuring universe and
there's only a couple i really don't
like yeah
some pretty solid chillers over the
course of this cinematic universe
yeah yeah you got like your entertaining
blockbuster horror movies
and on the other side you get like your
psychological horrors like babadooks and
hereditaries and whatnot
and then here you know this is like the
fun theater experience or the hbo max
sitting at home experience yeah yeah but
you know yeah i get what you mean and
the conjuring
the first conjuring was certainly
something of a return to that
blockbuster scale of haunted house
chiller movies and stuff and i'm glad
that that tradition remains because
you know the conjuring and especially
the conjuring flagship
series seems to do a pretty good job of
that and i mean this is a different
director this time
yeah it's michael schaubs who did the
legend of uh la yorona you got the
director's name right but you got the
movie wrong you said the legend
you're already idiot
which you know isn't the most inspiring
thing to hear but then you see at least
the grip on the visuals and the tone of
this trailer and you can sort of see
then how
decisions got made for him to succeed
james one because it doesn't look
like a complete left turn out of his
style necessarily you know well i think
it's smart to get a different director
uh
i think it's appropriate to get a
different director i would say i don't
know
right where it's smart for this
installment
because the style is so different in
terms of what the plot is like the other
ones are
family driven dramas and then they have
a haunting to deal with you know very
like
it's not exactly poltergeist but you
know more along those lines
that familiar domestic haunting yeah 100
here this
is uh a little bit more like exorcism of
emily rose where you're dealing with a
real life court case and from my
understanding this is a real life court
case they ha
that they had some involvement in or at
least the the trial was real i don't
know if
and lorraine warren are you know these
things are hiding i mean
they were brought in as yeah consultants
on the trial and to testify and
what the main determining factor yeah i
mean this certainly pits them as like
they were at the center of this
crazy other worldly satan conspiracy
but it's so entertaining oh yeah it's
wildly entertaining i love
that kind of plot i love that kind of
direction that they're going with it so
to mix it up with a different director
on
when you're changing the structure of
your movie that's what i mean by how
that feels appropriate yeah
it might be more noticeable if it was
like another
family who's being haunted you know what
i mean it comes down to the to the
scripting as well because you know la
yorona
is not the flagship and i feel like they
put the most oomph
into the conjuring films so this makes
me excited to see what this director can
do with a more solid
skill and more stuff to play with well
the opening scene kind of reminded me of
texas chainsaw massacre a little bit
yeah yeah first of all
yeah when i'm watching this trailer i'm
getting a bit of
a mixture of that sort of psychological
killer investigate kind of like a david
fincher
but mixed it with james one i feel
that's kind of like a hybrid i'm feeling
here with the direction like david
fincher meets james wan in this trailer
you know what
i'm sticking to that you should coin
that point start quoting yourself that's
what this trailer is what a brilliant
thing i said in one trailer reactions
just like i don't know if i'd say
brilliant it is i might say
genius genius yes god level observations
maybe we should be called the rain and
ed warren
they really should rain is always
putting her
damn soul on the line and all these
movies
and that's always like three right now
he's just jamie the root that's really
controversial
it's going too far yeah now he's going
to dive off the edge of a cliff in order
to save her indiana jones style
yeah she's a real champ of this dude
i love them together i can't wait to i
hope he plays guitar again
i do too i mean yeah i part of that is
the heart and soul of like peeking in on
the moments that aren't the
i mean this looks like the most bonkers
of the three of them in terms of like i
feel like the whole like based on a true
story thing is
is like completely awash now because
like this looks so insane
it's so expansive like the other ones
are usually one location or is there iso
way too high
this one feels expansive in the sense of
it's not like eden lorraine in the big
city
or she got like new york major set
locations everywhere
it's still in a small town essentially
you know it's still in like the
countryside helps keep it still grounded
for
what the contrary movies are with
crowded grounded with the biggest
asterisk you could possibly find
grounded as compared to some of the
other conjuring spin-offs but i mean
this one does look like it has the
biggest most bonkers most horror movie
set pieces
and what i'm most looking forward to
other than like you know reading curses
and demonic possessions like that's
always fun i'm most looking forward to
how the law enforcement is going to
react to everything like that scene
where
all the cops are just kind of watching
them in the witness interrogation room
it looks so fun just oh yeah who's going
to believe these guys you know well
and i mean that is something i think is
interesting because that could lead to
maybe a scrap of heightened relevance or
heightened sort of real world
application because you know the
warren's legacy is
one that is uh contentious to certain
people that is
up for debate for a lot of people as
much as these movies
pitch them like that's often the
complaint i hear about these movies is
like
lorraine warren took advantage of all
these people uh so i'm curious to see if
they'll explore any of that in here
through the
eyes of the police because especially
knowing how the trial ends up
you know it seems like there would be a
good cause for friction
from law enforcement with them yeah i'm
actually not familiar with the trial
uh but it seems like this movie movie's
taking the approach you know how the
exorcism
everything rose has you debating whether
or not it is a demonic possession
or not yeah uh this movie is insane it's
a hundred percent
absolutely a demonic possession here's
the truth
that thing where it's like he was a
killer really and demon was attached to
him
yeah especially one that you predict
months in advance all right
all right guys what'd you think of the
conjuring the devil made me do it
trailer
subscribe to god to protect you from
satan hit that like button that gets a
message to all the angels out there
click that notification bell to get
notified
when jesus is at your doorstep see you
guys